en este vídeo vamos a hablar acerca de
algunos términos que utilizamos para
hablar de los circuitos y de cómo los
construimos en vídeos anteriores ya
hemos hablado acerca de los componentes
o elementos que utilizamos para
construir los circuitos por ejemplo ya
hemos hablado acerca de los resistor es
capacitores inductores todos esos son
los componentes de nuestros circuitos
aunque también les llamamos elementos
también tenemos algunas fuentes como la
fuente de voltaje o la fuente de
corriente ok
estos son los componentes o también
conocidos como elementos de un circuito
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es empezar
a ensamblar estos formando circuitos
nuclear pero todavía nos falta un poco
de terminología por ejemplo tenemos por
aquí algunos componentes de circuitos y
los vamos a conectar con un cable por
ejemplo podría conectar a éste
con este utilizando este cable ideal y
por cierto los cables ideales tienen
cero resistencia y es perfecto en todos
los sentidos en todos lados y entonces
este cable está formando una conexión
entre estos dos componentes y a esto
nosotros le llamamos un nodo nodo es la
palabra que utilizamos para describir a
esta unión si también se nos ocurre unir
a estos otros dos componentes entonces
todo esto es un mismo nodo ok porque
toda esta es una misma conexión y en
todos lados tienen exactamente el mismo
voltaje bueno ahora nos vamos a ir a
este circuito y vamos a identificar
todos sus nodos por cierto este circuito
sobre como un circuito bastante normal
se ve como un circuito muy ordenado y
sencillo por aquí tenemos un nodo que
conecta a esta resistencia con esta
fuente de voltaje así es que este de
aquí es el primero
si nos movemos por aquí podemos ver a
estos tres resistor es conectados por
este cable ideal así es que aquí tenemos
un solo nodo que es el nuevo número dos
y ahora vamos por aquí nuevamente veo a
este cable ideal que está conectando a
estos resistor es con la fuente de
voltaje así es que este es el nodo
número 3 entonces este circuito tiene
tres nodos y ahora qué es lo que está
conectando a todos estos nodos bueno
pues las cosas que conectan a los nodos
se llaman ramas aunque entonces tenemos
por aquí una rama y en este circuito las
ramas son justo los componentes del
circuito por ejemplo aquí la fuente de
voltaje conecta al nuevo 3 con el nodo 1
este es un elemento o sea una rama este
resistor conecta al nodo 1 con el nodo 2
entonces es la rama número 2
este resistor conecta al nodo 2 con el
nuevo 3 por lo cual es la rama número 3
este otro resistor con una corriente
independiente también conecta al nodo 2
con el nodo 3 entonces es la rama número
4 este circuito de aquí tiene 1 2 3 4
elementos y cuatro ramas aunque tiene
cuatro ramas bueno ahora nos vamos a ir
con este otro circuito que es un poquito
menos sencillo que el anterior así es
que vamos a repetir este proceso tenemos
que empezar por contar los nodos por
aquí tenemos un nodo entre este resistor
y esta fuente de voltaje ok
este es el nuevo uno aquí tenemos tres
resistor es conectados por un cable
perfecto ideal así es que este es el
nuevo dos aquí tenemos otros tres
resistor es conectados por un cable
perfecto así es que este es el nodo 3
aquí tenemos dos resistor es unidos por
un cable perfecto que es el novo 4 y
finalmente tenemos aquí a este cable
perfecto uniendo a estos cuatro
elementos en
un solo nodos ya veces se le llama nodo
distribuido porque ella es el nodo 5 es
un nuevo distribuido cuando llega a
tantos lugares del circuito pero sigue
siendo exactamente un solo nodo así es
que este circuito tiene 5 nodos y si
contamos los elementos lo cual nos va a
decir la cantidad de ramas que tiene
este circuito entonces tenemos 1 2
4 5 6 y 7 tenemos siete elementos bueno
tenemos aquí estas dos palabras claves
en la terminología de circuitos tenemos
elementos y nodos y ahora voy a mover la
pantalla para ver a estos otros dos
circuitos porque vamos a empezar a
hablar del concepto de las mallas mayas
y de la otra cosa de la que vamos a
hablar es de los lazos y bueno la
palabra maya proviene en realidad de los
mosquiteros seguramente en algún momento
has visto un mosquitero que son estas
rejillas así pero con los ojitos muy
pequeños como para que no pasen por ahí
los insectos son un montón de cables y
tos por ahí y justo este espacio de
enmedio aquí a este espacio nosotros le
vamos a llamar malla porque lo que
realmente queremos hacer es encontrar
las mallas de nuestro circuito por aquí
tenemos las ramas de nuestro circuito
y una malla es como un lazo que está en
el espacio que dejan las ramas es el
espacio rodeado por los cables que unen
a las ramas así es que este circuito
tiene una malla una segunda malla así es
que este circuito tiene tres mallas para
dibujar una malla empiezas en un nodo y
vas pasando por los elementos hasta que
vuelves a regresar a ese mismo nodo
así es como hicimos a estos tres y
llenan los espacios vacíos en el
circuito así es que este circuito tiene
tres mallas ahora en realidad las mallas
son lazos gay pero también hay otros
tipos de lazos los lazos no son
únicamente los que cubren los espacios
vacíos del circuito así es que este
circuito además de tener todas estas
mallas también tiene otros lazos por
ejemplo podemos empezar en este nodo y
irnos por acá
y hacer toda esta vuelta y este también
es un lazo claro que también hay otros
lazos más y los vamos a dibujar todos
con diferentes colores por ejemplo ahora
si empiezo por aquí puedo dibujar un
lazo que pase por todos estos elementos
y si ponemos mucha atención podemos
encontrar un último lazo aunque hoy es
un lazo que va todo a lo largo del
exterior del circuito entonces cuántos
lazos tiene este circuito
bueno pues están los tres lazos que
dibujamos por aquí pero las mallas
también son lazos entonces tenemos seis
lazos este circuito tiene seis lazos los
circuitos siempre tienen muchísimos
lazos entonces generalmente hablamos más
bien de la cantidad de mallas que tiene
un circuito bueno pues ya terminamos con
este vídeo vimos los términos de mallas
de lazos también estuvimos hablando de
los componentes y elementos y también
hablamos un poco acerca de los términos
y ramas así es que ya terminamos ya
tenemos nuevo vocabulario para poder
hablar fluidamente acerca de los
circuitos